hey guys I'm Luke Smith from Bungie and
today we're gonna talk about your
questions on this episode of Destiny
support the first one is from Matt BFC
Gmail 1 which I'm a little worried that
that might be a password of his but
let's get to his question I think bungle
should reinstate a loot cave somewhere
just for the hell of it you can see how
many people are willing to grind that
shiz
well the loot cave was a pretty fun time
in Destiny 1 and what it showed us was
that the game that we shipped in 2014
was a game that people wanted to play
and that it also wasn't rewarding enough
what we've tried to do with destiny and
now destiny 2 is to make the game feel
pretty rewarding so that's standing in
front of a cave shooting into it isn't
the best way to play it the loot cave
questions continue what if Bungie never
patched out the loot cave well we all
still be sitting in front of that cave
farming engrams even though I hope not
there's like a little part of me that
thinks there would still be some people
standing in front of the loot cave
shooting into it and hope that something
amazing was going to come out of it and
so we did it we did it to prevent that
from happening since the black garden is
the requirement for carryover could the
strangers rifle be destiny ones
remembrance piece for original players I
think what you're asking about here
sungkoo it's is how is Bungie going to
remember that we play destiny 1 we have
something we're planning we're not gonna
talk about it I'm not gonna spoil it
here but when the game comes out on
September 6th you'll find out for
yourself what I'm talking about
will there be any destiny 2 perks for
players of D 1 if we need to buy it on
the same platform for them to work
you're gonna enter the world a little
differently than people who didn't play
d1 well you need to buy it on the same
platform for them to work the answer to
that is yes if you're an Xbox player in
destiny 2 on xbox we will remember
and show you that we remember when you
boot up the game and into the world
question :
did the wizard really come from the moon
or was that just something you guys said
to get people interested we talked a lot
about this one
internally we think that the wizard did
in fact come from the moon and what we
didn't
good job of was communicated that the
wizard came from the moon like giving
you a different name like moon wizard or
lunar wizard or something like that
we'll try to do better
scathe Locke Auto rifle is the best gun
in the D Stinney to beta that had two
E's yay or nay there were only a couple
of auto rifles in the beta and it was
just a tease scathe Locke is a kinetic
auto rifle which means it's gonna deal
bonus damage to players weak spots there
are their critical loans their heads so
if a player is just running around not
in their super scape Locke might have
been the best auto rifle in the beta but
our energy weapons we also had an auto
rifle I believe in the beta and so if a
player was in there super you know
running around like running around
throwing shields like you know Captain
America then that auto rifle probably
would be better than scathe Locke so the
answer to this question really is about
the answer to how we think about the
sandbox for destiny I hope skate looks
amazing I hope it ships and it's an
incredible weapon and people love it but
I hope it's got times when it's really
great and times when you wish you're
using something else
if the awoken weren't created until
after the darkness arrived why does it
awoken Guardian not know what happened
to the traveler this is a tricky
question because it sort of lays bare
the timeline and the question - the
timeline can create so I'm going to talk
about one particular part of the
timeline the collapse and we chose the
word collapse at Bungie very
specifically we were trying to indicate
that not only did society collapse but
it also sort of you know jet like
jettisoned humanity back into the
equivalent of a sort of Dark Age so not
much is actually remembered at all from
this time and it's it's very deliberate
why does the queen of the awoken have my
haircut if this picture is
representative this individuals hair has
since grown out since this question so
this might be a bit of a deep cut one of
the ways we think about character
creation is how how are we creating a
character who can be you know cosplayed
by people who love our game so choosing
those characters hairstyles and their
coloring and the way their the way their
zippers have little things on them it's
just humbling to see any character from
our game world that someone spent a
bunch of time to to like dress up and
embody it's it's it's always amazing and
the team gets super excited about it I
want to know
how the taken king in the vex play into
the war against the red Legion main that
is ma Y and II that's a word that I'm
probably not allowed to say cuz I'm too
old but because it was in the question I
read it and I committed to it while we
were building the taken King we had an
idea about what was coming next and we
knew it was going to be about the Cabal
we had a mission where you learned a
little bit about the fact I believe the
mission was called outbound signal and
the a mountain signal was in fact a
signal I believe it was a signal from
the Cabal ship that crashed into the
hive dreadnought that was beaming a
signal out to the Cabal empire with
respect to the vex the vex don't play
specifically a role in the the conflict
between the red Legion but while you're
playing through destiny - and while
you're playing a bunch of the different
content we are pointing at places we're
gonna go next part of the fun of making
and playing games is seeing that
intention and knowing that it's all it's
all going somewhere
FMJ underscore steward asks my name is
byph popular youtuber and lore master
what do you think about Kade being on
the vex planet in destiny - stuck in a
portal looking for the stranger or Maya
Sundaresh I can answer this one kate is
actually looking for neither of those
things he's trying to figure out a way
to solve this Gul problem in the opening
of the game in the first mission
homecoming which people played in the
beta kid talks about you know he's gonna
go find the person who caused this and
it's gonna be a short date that didn't
break well for Kade he he ended up
heading to necess
to try to figure out another way to
leverage technology because he doesn't
have his power anymore so that he can
take on Gaul and so it's not about the
stranger and it's not about Maya it's
about Kade doing the thing that I don't
think people expected him to do which
was be a hero
how does destiny look so realistic the
destiny visual style is a testament to
the amazing team of artists that we have
at the company like we have a visual
style for our worlds that dates back to
destiny one we describe it as nature
ascending over humanity a bunch of
awesome stuff happens like you have
giant bosses and you have like
characters throwing magic bombs and you
have
summoning golden magic pistols and so we
want to have that but at the same time
we want things to be grounded I'll be
frank why should anyone get destiny -
I'm console for anything but PlayStation
4 other than quote I don't own a ps4 I'm
gonna be frank the best place to play
destiny - is in the place where you can
play it with people you want to play
games with play wherever you want but
just play with people wise
double underscore got a rogue Acorah
here you know if she falls over and
people are gonna think I like
disrespected her or something so I'm not
gonna hear the end of it so she's got to
stand up I'll fix it yeah fixed any
change to the player fantasy do Titans
feel like walking tanks hunters like
acrobats of death and warlocks as
floating butterflies do you want a job
that's what we try to do so the hunters
with the new subclass the arc Strider we
tried to make an acrobat of death the
warlocks with dawn blade are floating
butterflies and the Titans we hope to
feel like walking tanks so if you want
to feel fast on any class what you want
to do is find armor that prioritizes
mobility if you want to feel like a
walking tank you're gonna want to find
armor that prioritizes resilience and
recovery no matter what class you're on
what we've done was we've made the stat
ranges on these statistics and destiny
to matter more so people in the beta
talked about you know my character
doesn't feel as fast as as he or she
felt in in destiny 1 so if you want to
be like a race car warlock there's
totally a build for that I'm not gonna
tell you what the stuff is in it cuz I
don't want to ruin the surprise
but if you want to go fast you can go
fast this is still wise double
underscore wolf so I'm just doing two at
once
any word on recovery armor or agility
did they throw that out or refine it so
that matters could we just run the same
answer I just gave I just run it twice
that'll be awesome how do you think
having power weapons instead of both
special and heavy affect the PvE endgame
definitely affects the PD endgame one of
the changes we've made
we have now characters went previously
we've called them majors which is not
word we never wanted you to like have to
understand as a player but any character
you're fighting whose health bar is not
like the boring like simple red version
like the baseline version of the unit
any one of those characters that you
fight is gonna just drop power ammo for
you suddenly that creates an interesting
game and it creates a prioritization
game when you're playing in something
like a strike by adding the sort of
deterministic way of giving ammo it lets
us design experiences so we do hope that
that when you're playing the game this
fall you can see that intention I think
ultimately it's gonna be it's gonna be
super fun for players the elemental mods
and the elemental weapons makes me think
we'll be able to change damage type yes
it does it doesn't mean that you'll be
able to change all the damaged colors
like for your exotics it does mean that
that you will be able to look at a hand
cannon that you love and be like oh man
I'm gonna I'm gonna change this to to
solar because I know that this week the
the Cabal strike and in the nightfall
playlist has a bunch of guys with red
shields I don't think this was in the
beta but when you pop the shields and
they match in in the shipping game so if
you're shooting a red shield with a red
gun it creates this pretty large AoE
explosion that deals damage not only the
character whose shield you just pops
they take sort of double damage on the
shield pop but also stuns the character
so they like freeze and just can keep
shooting him but the AoE will also blow
up a bunch of the creatures around them
so that damage match game becomes more
important and more fun next one can we
hope to have private matches on destiny
too in the first few updates after
launch what we're gonna be doing when
the game comes out is we have an
internal I'll fix it we're already
thinking about end of the game and we
have like it's like a you know a list of
features and then the game comes out and
the best-laid plans explode so it's
really hard for me to say right now yes
yes private matches are coming in the
first few updates after launch because
the plan is gonna be modified the deals
gonna be altered
sometime after September 6th when you
all out there get your hands on our game
hashtag destiny to thought : do you
think Bungie possibly begins utilizing
something like PTR on PC to test updates
with players before they go live so
PTR for those of you who aren't aren't
aren't like attuned to the Blizzard
language means patch test realm where we
go and play the latest content or we
play sort of a future update and we're
putting them printing the game through
its paces we have talked a lot
internally about the possibility of
opening something like this up to two
player groups and honestly I like the
idea of players not totally knowing
everything that's there before the game
comes out and well I think that test
realm and like private test beta if we
expanded that would be amazing for a
bunch of things like stability I'm still
interested in challenging us to do our
best job without having to expose it to
the public I wouldn't say never but I
wouldn't say yes I don't know how to get
that done to 140 characters it's tough
I'm liking the look of hash tag destiny
too but come on
at Bungie I remove the grimoire two
steps forward and one step back winky
face
now Stubbs I think you and I both know
that's a passive-aggressive winky face I
believe it was at diario where this
first thing leaked this this notion of a
lortab on a bunch of weapons that's one
of the elements that's our version of
how do we replace how do we replaced the
thing players love about the grimoire
and what I think the thing that players
love about the grimoire is its extending
the universe of destiny it's it's giving
it more teeth it's giving you more to
grab on to we don't feel like it was
necessarily taking something away but
rather reprioritizing the time that we
would spend on doing something out of
the game to put it in the game rather
than just the subset of people go to our
website we like lore too and the best
way for players to experience lore is
for them to experience it in the game
client I think that Titan is the best
class in the beta so far multiple slams
is Opie who's your favorite and why my
friends and I played a bunch of
competitive we played a bunch of
countdown in the beta and for me in a
mode with objectives it was hard for me
to have more fun than dropping big walls
while I'm playing the Titan class
ability I think it's like towering
barricade is what it's called that's a
mouthful besides call it big wall but
a path the gunslinger tree that I think
is pretty much the best we've ever seen
for hunters in PvE
it's called the way of the Sharpshooter
and the way that it works
each hit of your Golden Gun can now do
precision damage okay so you can you can
critical hit with Golden Gun successive
precision hits of Golden Gun deal more
damage and it does not to be on the same
target so you could you could hit
something with power a and then a plus 1
and a plus 2 now the next thing that it
does is each precision hit creates orbs
for your allies so if you're a good
golden gunshot and you pride yourself on
precision the way of the Sharpshooter is
the highest orb generation class that
I've seen in the game to date now I'm
not gonna just like ignore the Warlock
either there's a path for the void
Walker I just called the devourer path
and this is a path or the void Walker
gets to put him or herself into a state
it's called devourer and when devourer
is active which I can do two ways I can
do it by like consuming my grenade I can
eat a grenade or with a melee kill or
you just like Bop a guy and kill them
either of those things will set you into
the devourer state that any kill will
start to heal you and of course when
you're super full you get to throw the
Denova bomb and the snow of a bomb on
the bottom tree travels much faster than
the the Nova bomb the top tree that was
in the beta that I affectionately call
Slovo bomb but I believe the game calls
Cataclysm so I can't buy Talent I kind
of take the coward's way out in this one
I honestly don't really have a favorite
I sort of moved between the characters
you know based on my mood but for me I'm
gonna have a couple of day ones because
I'm gonna have the consult day one in
September and then of course I'm gonna
have the PC day one in October and the
thing I will promise you is I will play
two different characters on each of
those day ones and I bet you by the time
the PC comes out I'll have leveled all
three of the characters already cuz I
play a lot of the game can't you tell at
so sweaty
if the dawn blade can kill a hunter and
Golden Gun with one strike why can't the
hunter do the same with one golden
gunshot Don blade has a travel time
which means it's dodgeball so when you
throw the flaming sword it moves
and it can be avoided it's not a it's
not like an instant hit projectile from
range Golden Gun is I believe this is
probably just going off of the beta and
so this is just looking at the
six-shooter talent a precision hit with
Golden Gun but probably kill the Don
blade warlock so you might be looking
for the way the Sharpshooter what is the
best power weapon in the destiny to beta
he's linked to YouTube clip here and I
bet you it's just like someone doing
unfair things with some power weapon for
us to guess without watching the clip
without making it play behind me it
might be a fusion rifle the fusion
rifles were a little hot they were a bit
strong and so we are gonna we're gonna
tune them down just a smidge to bring
him in line with the other power weapons
we've looked at things like hyper flinch
and sniper sway and I've tried to try to
reduce that we've done things like
increase rocket launcher damage against
the monsters we hope there isn't a best
when the game ships I mean the one this
one over here it's pretty good it's
called the ward if coil so no more
doobies valley it's a power weapon you
call it the ward if coil that's its name
I don't think I understand what a power
weapon is in the destiny to beta is it a
heavy is it a secondary capital wth is
it a power weapon in the beta is a
weapon that has no ammo when you spawn
and all the ammo for it is located
around the map now in the PvP game these
weapons are all pretty much one hit kill
weapons very effective they're super
lethal and you don't have access to them
all the time we want to make combat
engagements be more like gunfights
rather than rather than what they've
been in the past cuz we are an action
game and we're a shooter what a power
weapon is is it's an opportunity to win
it's a big opportunity to win it's a
temporal advantage it's like a power
plant hockey in a bunch of way it's like
you have the advantage Titans have
mobile fist of havoc and hunters have
golden guns why don't we have a mobile
Nova bomb for warlocks like three to
four smaller bombs like three to four
smaller bombs made of fire like swords
could that work cuz you have that
could be we call that good let's call
that good what weapon are you guys gonna
miss the most in destiny - double
question mark hashtag destiny - I'm not
gonna speak for the whole team I will
only speak for myself its weapon that I
wanted from the moment we created it
there was a weapon that when I got it
I stood up in my living room and let out
a Yelp and a fist pump and my golden
retriever looked at me like I was a
lunatic it is a weapon that was found in
destinies first raid the vault of glass
and it came from the Templar raid boss
and its tool tip is delivering the
inevitable one trigger pull at a time
and its name was fate bringer and I will
miss it forever legitimate question
Kinkaid 6 even eat ramen - EXO's even
eat I didn't ask a version of this
question internally but I did ask
another question about EXO's
capabilities because I did wonder you
know it's a robot like is it like you
know like is it automatic
yeah like the answers index for fun and
so like of course yeah Kade of course
can eat ramen like of course he can kid
can eat anything that you can eat and I
guess he really likes the spicy ramen i
fun fact I don't like spicy things
because it gives me heartburn makes me
upset
it makes me grumpy well cayde-6
have a bigger role in destiny too in the
context of how big the game is kate has
a part and he shares that part with the
two other members of the vanguard
because you wanted to give each of them
their own sort of arcs in the game in
terms of objective does he have more
stuff to do in this game than any
doesn't he game previously he does and
it goes further because Kade just like
the other members of the Vanguard has a
little role that they play in the
cyclical game which is the game you play
after the campaign if gahl listened to
music what type of music would he listen
to true story I actually got some folks
from the team together to talk to them
about this question because I wanted to
know the truth
the answer was music that would make him
feel superior
included things like jazz frog rock from
the 60s or 70s like you know maybe Gauls
really into Rush
although in my head if I were Gaul I
think I might listen to some of that
stuff from Milano I really do want us
good stuff should check it out quick
question for destiny lore people why
does lord shaxx have the raised lighter
sword instead of the Guardian in Canon
Wow in Canon you and your ghost we're
not at the tower at the time of the
attack Jax just that says all the time
and also like it's a glowing flaming
sword like you want to look at the guy
and be like yep what's the coolest thing
we can give him well we're not allowed
to give him a lightsaber so what's the
next coolest thing a sword that's on
fire let's do that looks sweet you
didn't have yours you're losing your
wall long while the rest your stuff that
the guy listening to smooth jazz blew up
we're sorry well I mean yes oh you did a
really good job I think I could have
done a better job
I tried I'll see you with a whole bunch
more this fall in destiny too and thanks
for watching this episode a destiny
support